all right so the time has come I've done
my top ten list of my favorite movies of
2019 now the worst which is keep in mind
there are no mistakes just happy
accidents though we know the truth you
and I I'm wearing a shirt of Lies but a
lot of the same rules of my best list
apply to my worst list one I haven't
seen every movie this year with the
worst ones very consciously so quite a
few times I was like no I'm gonna skip
it which means there are a few choices
on here where in the words of the great
Tom Riddle I confess myself disappointed
also these aren't reviews gonna say a
few things and move on I'll put links
below to the movies that I list on here
if you want to see a review for them
also this video is gonna be biased as
[ __ ] which means welcome all to my
unprofessional subjective and completely
biased video of the top 10 worst movies
of 2009 date and we start with number 10
but starting off the list it's 47 meters
down subtitle I forgot what 47 meters
down to look 47 meters down actually had
a pretty sweet premise and it was
actually very claustrophobic considering
the fact that there were no walls
anywhere just the open of the dark deep
under the ocean was claustrophobic
enough it did what Hollywood does which
a few movies on this list did which is
go well that was a neat premise that
kind of worked we'll just throw more
into there make a sequel will less is
more then you had blind sharks it was
just a mess of a movie couple of good
shark moments but I forgot about the
movie until I had to comb through my
reviews to find the top 10 worst I was
like oh yeah that movie happened which
is a very big clue that it's not good
enough to remember 9 next up the curse
of La Llorona am I saying that right
I heard I have such a thick American
accent well you got a tux [ __ ] about my
accent I don't talk [ __ ] about your
accent this movie is lifeless scare
tactic horror movie nonsense which I
guess is part of the conjuring universe
which means the conjuring universe it
probably got there a little before this
movie but it's definitely there now
which is the point of us going yeah
we're sick II you know I see no more
conjuring movies for the rest of my life
I'll be totally fine kind of funny
because the conjuring kind of breathed
life into the horror movie genre and it
went on for so long that apparently it
just it drained its own life next up
it's the final I cannot say the title
with us singing that stupid I can't
now this movie I'll give it credit
really solid premise right there an app
that shows you when you're gonna die you
could do a hundred things with that
promise unfortunately for the minds that
made this nonsense that they didn't see
it like that we're like let's just do a
lot of what horror movies do and let's
be boring about it supid alright we all
agree right we all agree terminators
should not be a franchise right
we know that terminator dark fate is one
of those movies that was made by someone
who just I don't think they saw
terminator 1 & 2 terminator 1 & 2 I
rewatched terminator 1 & 2 after
terminator dark fate and it did two
things it made me gaze upon those films
that I already loved and I saw them with
a renewed sense of pride and an
enjoyment you know appreciation also it
made me hate terminator dark fate more
every action there is an equal and
opposite reaction
look when you're taking on a movie
that's a sequel you have to respect the
universe it comes from and it's just I
don't think they did that but not just
that it's just it's a terminator movie
it's a terminator sequel like we've seen
terminator sequels be before it's a
rehash of the same old stuff that's not
as good as the good old stuff but yeah
stop with those it's done see next up
okay they [ __ ] terminator into the
ground but The Lion King it's infallible
you could never do that wrong unless of
course you make a lifeless cash-grab
version of it a husk of The Lion King
geysers movie had no soul that had no
life what was it it's a live action Lion
King movie that's actually a Lion King
animation which proves you can make a
Lion King animation and make it suck ass
this one hurts because the Lion King is
just loved that's what I have the best
moments in this movie were the moments
that were new that had new dialogue for
this movie unfortunately this movie
tries to just redo the same dialogue
with different actors that have
different inflection and the dialogue of
the old animation wasn't made for these
versions of these characters just the
movie was a mess another movie I ended
up hating more as time went on I didn't
like it initially but at this point burn
baby burn five okay I'm gonna be real
when I saw that David Harbor was the new
Hellboy I was actually pretty excited I
was like that works I saw pictures like
yeah that looks dark it looks gritty it
looks
then I saw the movie and I felt dark and
gritty and dirty myself this is the
textbook case of a remake or a reboot
that just didn't need to happen nothing
in this new Hellboy is done better than
the guerra mo del Toro Hellboy del Toro
ones were fun and cool but also had
great mythology but someone was asleep
at the wheel making this thing I don't
know if there was studio meddling to go
along with this thing but I got the same
sense of fan for stick when I walked out
of here going that that movie was so
shoddy it had to have been a studio
thing there had to have been Minds
clashing and that end product was the
result of that clash otherwise everyone
on board was like that's the best we got
that's just worse x-men movies they've
had hits they've had misses and the
x-men universe as we know it I imagine
has now come to a close because they'll
probably be brought into the MCU the
x-men franchise surely went out not with
a bang but a whimper
all right insanity is doing the same
thing over and over again and expecting
different results so when you have the
writer of x-men 3 The Last Stand the
movie that kind of butchered the Dark
Phoenix saga and you have that person
right Dark Phoenix again what did you
expect oh [ __ ] that writer directed this
movie - I totally forgotten that's the
cherry on top
what takes anyhow the characters weren't
done justice I mean granted Nightcrawler
stabbed people in the neck because you
know he's a killer believed they were
aliens if I'm remembering correctly
still sentient beings I'm done bitching
about this when x-men movies have had
great they've had terrible this is
terrible all right a social message in
your movie that's fine Hollywood's been
doing that for years decades Z but black
Christmas showed us that you still need
a movie I'm fine look long story short
if you're gonna make a movie that's
heavy-handed with its message you still
need to have the movie succeed in the
genre it's an but as a horror movie this
movie sucks
it's boring it has no thrills that are
almost insulting intelligence of the
audience with the lack of nuance with
its message a movie with a message does
not a good movie make and this movie
does not succeed as a horror movie
two cats is the reason top ten worst
list exists cats is the kind of movie
you need a shirt that says I sat through
cats watching cats should get you free
pancakes at IHOP on the anniversary of
the release of the movie okay that's a
little that's a little extreme but holy
you know when Yoda said fear leads to
anger anger leads to hate hate leads to
suffering that's what this movie is I
feared going into it I was angry when I
was watching it I hated myself after
watching it because I undeniably
suffered I heard it's getting DLC though
I heard they're cleaning up the CGI and
they're gonna re release it don't even
bother
well they still rerelease it guys anyhow
like I said in my review pornhub is
gonna get much more interesting or at
least Google Images those are some
thirsty Kitty [ __ ] you've never looked
up Zootopia you've never searched judy
hopps really me neither
cats isn't number one well that's just
crazy maybe but one of the first movies
I saw in 2019 was replicas with Keanu
Reeves and it kind of just set the bar
from then on I was just waiting for a
movie to beat it and it just it never
happened maybe it's because I've
suffered with the memory of replicas
longer it's just one of those movies you
got to ask Keanu why I've heard Keanu
Reeves is known for helping his friends
out if they want him in a movie or
something like that maybe that's what
happened all I know is this movie is
like three Outer Limits sci-fi ish
movies wrapped into one and it just
doesn't work I mean the premise is great
maybe that's why I'm just more pissed at
the movie because the premise is good
and I think Keanu Reeves could have done
well in a movie like that cloning robots
consciousness oh my could have been
sweet but we just got a mess a wreck of
a movie in the CGI robot oh wow no it
hurt it really did I can't find a movie
on my list that's Messier that had more
potential to be good but also was just
as bad as it was the contrast between
the potential and the reality it's just
too vast it's too stark it's too deep
and replicas is just the shittiest movie
of 2019 for me my god we suffered
through some dog [ __ ] in 2019 didn't we
you and I actually you shouldn't have
like I take these hits so you don't have
to
if you do what are you doing hopefully
you're having fun if it's fun for you
great so that's it I've done the best
list I've done the worst list and that
wraps up 2019 for me still want to do a
video on Mandalorian series as a whole
so there is that so I suppose I'm not
done done but for the most part I'm done
and once again thank you very much for
another year of sticking around with me
I appreciate that in a world of much
more professional folk who now review
movies on YouTube I gotta assume the
reason you stick around with me is well
because it's me like my personality I
guess you like that and I like that so
thank you very much for another great
year on YouTube that I'm very thankful
for and I'm thankful for it because of
you we move on to 2020 where there will
be more great movies more dog [ __ ]
movies and yes more movies that are just
middle-of-the-road but that's my list of
the top 10 worst movies to 2019 per my
opinion I imagine you have your opinion
your list what is your list of the top
10 worst movies of 2019 if you don't
watch a lot of movies that you can make
it fewer than that you can make it 5 or
3 whatever they are whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you